head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
think about this 1.9 billion dollars the
cash payout is 929 million yeah no I was
gonna buy one today here's here's the
thing like I had been talked into it
people's lives get destroyed by the
lottery yeah because they don't
understand what happens when you have
money for like for people who've grown
up around it or earned their way into it
slowly you see this like imagine this
I'll tell you guys when you start
becoming when you start becoming more
successful people around you become evil
as evil can possibly be and you're and
you learn who your true friends really
are and then you also learn you know
who's like never really a friend but
they really want free stuff but it is it
is is unsurprising I mean
I I should say it was surprising to me
to discover how many people that you
think are your friends try not to be
just extremely evil yeah but imagine one
day you don't just earn your way into it
and experience it slowly over time where
you're like I can't believe someone
would do that to me this is crazy and
then after five years of you you know
continually being wealthy and successful
you're like I get it I gotta be on guard
and hire lawyers and have police have
security guards imagine one day you're
working class and next thing you're
worth 900 million dollars knives out all
the evil people instantly at once draw
their blades for you it's it's it's
I just want to make a really really
quick Point here I dated a girl who who
won the lottery and she was like I wish
I never won it because it ripped her
family apart and a lot of people who win
the lottery uh they're miserable because
of it and they lose the money very
quickly as well so what did you win like
millions or something uh yeah tens of
millions yeah Aaron Carter the younger
brother of Nick Carter from the
Backstreet Boys just died and you'll see
a lot of this and I mean again coming
from La you see a lot of people that
come into Fame quickly and there's two
different types of people that to come
into Fame it's you know someone like you
know pretty much you guys at this table
where you've had to kind of earn your
way up and it's kind of a grind but some
people sort of get plucked up by The
Establishment and they get put into a
Fame you know base and they do have
talent I'm not trying to say that it's
binary they do have talent but they get
plucked up so quickly and put into Fame
so quickly well he was nine when he did
his first video that's what I'm saying
right and so what can happen is that um
uh they get hooked on drugs they get too
many fake friends around them they get
they get ungrounded and in personal
growth and self-help the biggest thing
they talk about all the time is that if
you win the lottery it just destroys
your life you have to actually have the
psyche of somebody who's wealthy to be
able to maintain it I'm 100 sure I could
handle it you guys or something someone
just super chatted this to me Jay wood
shout out Trump was born during a blood
moon June 14th
check it out here it is on Wikipedia
1946 check it out born Donald J Trump
June 14th 1946. I looked it up wow June
14th 1946 lunar eclipse right there and
there it is the blood moon that could be
why he couldn't today that could be why
he could be announcing today he's gonna
announce at 3am he's gonna talk non-stop
that 300 like did the moon change yet
I'm running everybody he's still talking
right now I'm watching him talk right
now anyway anyway back to the lottery
stuff's interesting so uh well it's also
a psyche of being at the effect right
it's like these shows like uh these
shows that pluck up the average person
and make them famous or things like that
or reality TV or taking people that
aren't that talented and making them
famous it's more of this idea that the
establishment like that you're at the
effect of life then the big
establishment which is kind of like this
sort of like pimple relationship they
come up they pluck you up and then they
make you famous the way to get Success
is Not By grinding it out is by just
being this like perfectly compliant
person then they'll just pluck you up
and make you famous if Harvey
Weinstein's happy with you you're going
to get the role yeah exactly right right
if Les Wexner is happy with you you're
gonna get that modeling gig at
Victoria's Secret you know if Mr Epstein
or Mr Clinton are happy with you you
might get that good political job it's
also why a lot of bad governments get
elected because people are in that kind
of psychology so one of the biggest
things to actually changing what kind of
governments get elected is teaching
people to think for themselves I think
that's actually the battle of the coming
century is teaching people to think for
themselves teaching them not to use
groupthink as a easy out to thinking and
when you take someone especially like a
child and you make up like a Disney star
you see horrible ramifications when you
do that when you just throw them into
Fame and these parents that just give
their child to these den of vipers in
Hollywood seriously I mean when you look
at Hollywood there's a lot of you know
we're talking about spiritual stuff
there's a lot of satanic evil devilish
elements inside of Hollywood and and in
Washington DC where of course the
biggest amount of psychopaths kind of
coalesce and then they prey on the
innocent they take people and then they
bring them into and they give them all
this money and all this Fame they can't
handle it and then they they prey on
their weaknesses and their mistakes and
that's the entire establishment industry
that we're dealing with right now there
are a lot of parents though who
intentionally exploit their children for
you know various financial gain and
that's yeah that's crazy yeah it's crazy
but they do it not just in Hollywood
they do it all over yeah like Dwayne
Wade you know yeah like Dwayne Wright
yeah like the is being accused of being
accused with his model child right his
yeah I think he's also just very bought
into a certain narrative Dwayne Wade
seems like a very Gabriel Union helped
yeah like Dwayne Wade looks like an
exceedingly positive person but I think
he's very bought into a certain
narrative I think so too I also um
I've recently been like I think there's
an issue with stepmothers I know there's
some good stepmothers
they're crazy I've been thinking about
that myself the crazy thing I would tell
people about stuff like Lottery wins it
used to be that uh people would lose the
money really really fast they would
waste it on insane things and their
lives would be destroyed by it
recently because of documentaries
talking about this people that have
instantly started going to financial
advisors and then getting things set up
in order but the one thing you can't
advise away from is Humanity that it's
not even about you you can't like I'll
tell you man if you won 929 million
dollars
that that actually sounds nightmarish
you're going to have people trying to
kill you you're not gonna so like we we
get this all the time with uh death
threats swattings bomb threats it's just
it's nuts imagine not having any
experience with it not having dealt with
this level of of insanity and all of a
sudden one day overnight it's like oh
someone's gonna try and kill you
actually tons of people are gonna try
and kill you they know where you live
they announced you won good luck or they
just become infatuated by you and then
want to love you and become so centered
on you that they make you the focus of
their life and then they become
destructive in that way uh but one of
the smartest things that I saw was an
announcement for someone who won the
lottery and he decided to wear the
scream mask and he's literally getting
the check because some lotteries make
you uh have the photo make you of course
sign a lot of documents do a lot of PR
do a lot of news interviews he says I'm
not doing any of that I'm putting on a
mask he was photographed with the mask
and it's one of the smartest things that
that I've ever seen Anonymous he's like
I don't want I don't want family members
bothering me yeah it's all about my
family happiness about a certain amount
of money it's really about having a
beautiful ecosystem purpose in life and
you know great friends and stuff and so
if you're in an ecosystem of people that
aren't used to that kind of wealth and
that's who you're surrounded by
um there's this thing we we called an
Ras flip so it's reticular activation
system it actually explains why people
on the left or the right see the world
differently it's called Ras reticular
activation system it's selective focus
we see the world very very differently
we don't believe what we see we see what
we believe and so we have very very
selective focus so if Tim you mentioned
that you had a lot of people turn evil
on you as you got success I had a
similar experience it's actually
heartbreaking and it's confusing as hell
if you've never experienced it and so
what happens is that like they don't ask
for anything there's instantly become
evil it's crazy it's terrifying and it's
some of your best friends and and it's
not even that they've hurt you it's that
real friends stab you in the back and
it's dehumanizing and it's not about
politics like obviously for political
reasons people are out today but in my
experience it's like for literally no
reason maybe it's jealousy yeah it's it
so what it is called an res flip so
basically as your value changes what
they see in you changes so reticular
activation system just look this up I
would advise anybody to look this up and
selective focus once you get this you
see why people see the world differently
we have very very selective folks we
don't believe what we see we see what we
believe and what it's like if you have a
breakup with a significant other and
then first they idealize you because
they're getting something from you later
in a breakup they like say that there
was a hundred experiences let's just to
be round number right 98 of them are
positive two or negative well then when
they like you they focus on the 98
positive then if you break up and it
hurts then they focus more on the two
negative ones the RS flip a year later
you forget the bad things start to
remember all the good things and then
wonder why you broke up 100 and so and
and that's why it's it's human to do
that but you're getting that same effect
as you've gained success that's why
you've seen that people are having res
flips they're seeing things differently
once you study this and you basically
just understand res it clarifies a ton
of Select what about have you seen
anything like that absolutely like time
and time again we were just talking
about this yesterday uh and and it's
it's real a lot of people have this kind
of Illusion a lot of people are
hypnotized that that money and fame are
something that is everything in life
when in reality it's it's usually a
burden more than it is a gift to
anything else and unless you grow into
it yeah yeah but essentially when people
just focus just on that and not the
journey and not their life and and not
the experiences and not the loved ones
that they have around them and they just
focus I want money I want money I want
fame I want fame they destroy everything
in their pathway and when they do get it
they're they're more miserable than
anyone else yeah the bhagavad-gita which
is a major Eastern text talks about the
process of being everything or you know
Eckhart totally Power of Now it's about
being present being in the now the
process itself the Bible they talk about
the same thing uh doubtaging they talk
about the same thing that you know the
beauty of life is in the present moment
the unfolding of the journey the energy
and money is a great thing too but it's
just one component yes absolutely but
you give it all a secret if you win if
you win that 1.9 billion that's all I
can say is just whatever don't tell
anybody about it yeah don't tell anybody
but you know what the problem is
that people are inexperienced this stuff
so they want to tell people they don't
get it they don't understand and they
don't have the money manager so the
government and the state takes what 52
percent of all of it you know do what
Bill Gates does get a non-profit get an
organization that you run donate all the
money there and then you can do whatever
you want with the money no it's sort of
well you could double your wealth just
like Bill Gates MC Hammer remember MC
Hammer Mike Tyson Mike Tyson lost all of
his money a lot of uh one of my staff
who got very wealthy very quickly he
actually blows money he called it and he
used to call it hammer time but he got
to blow all his money called hammer time
he'd say I EMC hammered all my money he
EMC hammered about a million dollars wow
wow he's made it back but yeah he had a
fun year
it's crazy man it really is nuts and
it's not it's not it's not about money
you know it's just like if crabs in a
bucket maybe jealousy I don't know it's
the res flip it's your value changes and
then it tweaks their perception again
um it's it's a really deep topic but it
okay simple version would be
um it kind of hijacks the part of the
brain that's very in the physical and so
you want to think of it like mind body
and soul right and so it gets them kind
of into their body the body is
inherently kind of sociopathic if you
look at like a nature documentary the
animals are killing each other eating
each other look at the ocean the fish
are eating each other so people can kind
of go into that mode and it's
unfortunate because politicians actually
manipulate this right if you can keep
everybody in that kind of primitive mode
then you can get them voting in bad
policies this is why critical thinking
and personal growth is going to be the
major battle the next 100 years I think
so weird though like why don't they feel
that way about Obama
uh because he's placating them but but
how I mean like look my point is this
when I say that people turn evil it's
like without Rhyme or Reason people in
my life what's an example uh just I'll
try to give a light example of some guy
I've known since I was a teenager we
used to hang out all the time skate
together we we were roommates briefly uh
just as just instantly started
smack talking me on online lying about
everything going to people and trying to
I don't know I think that may have been
like hey they thought maybe they could
get famous or something by claiming so
what it is is that in in personal growth
we would say that we live in the same
physical reality but we live in parallel
energetic realities and so what's
happened is you've entered into a
different energetic reality and they're
just living in a different reality it's
like if you took somebody homeless and
you bring them into a mansion they're PR
they might still be doing drugs in the
bathroom right they're not just gonna be
looking at the view so what happened is
you created a disconnect with them even
if you work with people and then you
keep elevating and they're not you'll
see there's there's a natural split it
just can't hold together
my point is like why doesn't a person
hold the negative view of other high
status people especially High status
people who are like deeply involved in
controversial things because because
you're close to them right but it's
almost like what amount of money would
have to be on this table before you'd
get uncomfortable would it be like if
there's a billion of if there was a you
might not because you're a principled
person but if there was a billion
dollars sitting right there would you
start getting any adrenaline or no no
okay well there's a point where
everybody okay well it's just money what
would be so much value to you that if it
was sitting right there you'd start to
be like whoa nothing I don't understand
so you're a very very principal person
well there's a point where people just
go crazy right so it's like like what's
people's breaking point where they'll
break their principles so one hobby that
I have I run seminars is um usually they
try to kick me out about midnight and so
I'll go to the person that wants to shut
down the room and I'll say
um could I say a bit longer they're like
no no I can't I say what about if I give
you 20 bucks and they're like no no I
can't and then I say what if I give you
500 bucks and then they're like oh of
course you know just say you're so they
crack the average person's principles
cracks Under Pressure but the reason why
you've been independently successful is
you have strong principles so they may
not have had that opportunity or focused
on personal Evolution they've probably
never had that discussion
that's amazing that you've done that
it's amazing you've done that but the
average person the average person is not
doing that they're not taught to they're
taught to look at Tick Tock I think it's
I think it's an issue of confidence too
I mean if someone like so look I worked
for a big evil media Corporation they
said well I said no and they were like
play balls like No And they offered me a
lot of money I was like I don't care
dude oh you know look
I have confidence in myself and I know
what I need and so I guess the issue is
perhaps some people are
evil and some people aren't and the evil
activates only in certain capacities
that is when presented with power with
it with with power that they could gain
so for me
you know uh if I was the way I often
describe it is if you're buck naked in
the middle of the woods that's Baseline
that's zero you have nothing but you're
actually not dying you're just you know
you're slowly heading towards a dark
place now if you're buck naked in the
middle of the woods you got a pointy
stick now you're up you're up one so you
actually got something there for all of
us here in this country we're at like 17
million because even as poor as you are
you've got you you're standing on a
street corner the government's going to
give you you got you got clean running
water available to you you walk into
McDonald's you get clean running water
you've got government services up the
Wazoo they're just giving people free
stuff so it's like we are so far
detached from Baseline in this country
there was I you're rich just being here
that's how that's how I I I've always
seen it I think that makes sense I feel
like that too like when you walk into
the grocery store do you ever walk into
the girls like uh so I used to do a lot
of acid and I would go to the groceries
all right Ian well whatever but I'd go
to the grocery store and I'd be like the
Bounty here is unbelievable I mean it's
just so much so that there is called
when you look at that when you look at
how much we have in this country like
it's it's very humbling and I think that
has so that so that is gratitude so so
that's beautiful that your State of
Consciousness experiences gratitude many
people do not expect there's it's it's
not just that like Tim you were saying
maybe some people are just evil and I
think very fully that all of us are
capable of being the most evil horrible
people that the world has ever seen and
you have to recognize this you have to
recognize your capability for a total
total horror for total evil to be just
the worst person possible and then you
have to be like okay I am capable of
this we are all capable of this that's a
very humbling place to be and then you
go about not using it and you find the
light and you I completely disagree you
go with the light I I I I don't think
every person is capable of evil perhaps
a lot of people are I think that evil is
inherent I mean I think that I think
that I don't I think there's I think
they're sociopaths and I think a lot of
people can't even justify or rationalize
and understand what the bigger
politicians and people in charge are
doing because they can't see themselves
doing it uh themselves I I see what you
guys are saying but I'll see what we
like when you see people that you love
right when you see people who you love
treat other people just absolutely
evilly and with horror like just
horribly and you know like I love this
person this person is capable of love
and they're treating this other person
who I also care about like so terribly
you can see how badly this can turn out
you can see how they mean it I think I
think when you're talking about is a
disowned Shadow right so you're saying
to recognize that in yourself you have
to recognize that and beat it yeah well
you just have to be humble to the in the
face of that I think you just have to
know what I I I think in glory using
things yeah I don't think so so if you
so typically when you have like a family
member mistreating a family member they
don't think they're a bad guy
mistreating a family member they might
you know like maybe you've got a dad
who's yelling at your sister well the
dad is yelling at her and and uh and I'm
talking about in a typical family
context not an abusive context like if
if there's a father who is mercilessly
beating his child congratulations you
found the evil person right I don't
think every human is capable of being
away I think every human is capable of
it I don't think every I don't think
every human succumbs to it I don't think
you know I but I think that everyone is
capable of being a monster in some form
or another I think everyone is capable
of that yeah I think some some people
are and some people aren't I I think
some people are completely incapable of
being that monster well there's also
something called cluster B right which
anti-personality disorder narcissistic
borderline all that stuff so yeah so
there's levels there's levels to all of
this right there's levels of trauma that
you've experienced as a kid your
upbringing
um the fact that you know 100 years ago
people might be reading the Bible
they're probably not now there's there's
a lot to this it's a very Perhaps
Perhaps the argument is you're saying
people many people have Evil Within them
and they have to fight against those
urges I think that would describe people
who have Evil Within them but I think
there are certainly people who aren't
evil I think that it's I think don't
have a hard time resisting greater risk
of succumbing to evil if you don't
recognize the human susceptibility to it
I guess what I'm saying is I think
they're I think some people are evil and
perhaps many of them resist the urges to
be evil and do evil and there's varying
degrees to which they are suppressed
from that some is by threat of physical
Force against them why they don't go
into the great grocery store full of
bounty and just take whatever they want
as they know someone will tackle them
and they'll get arrested well not these
days
and that's and that's because some
people are willing to engage in Acts of
let's say outright selfishness except
for physical deterrent some people have
social emotional deterrent meaning
they're scared they will be shunned and
ridiculed if they do it well some people
just genuinely don't want to do it right
and you but you're capable of it there
are people I don't want to do I'm saying
I I I think I think you're confusing the
action with like the desire which is
what I'm talking about I'm saying
someone who has absolutely no desire to
commit evil is sir I I guess they could
decide one day like I've never tried
evil but then they're clearly capable
what about the low-level flunkies and
authoritarians stay kids who go ahead
and commit the evil acts on behalf of
you know the authority in their in their
country and they just do it anyway like
when you look at the you know you look
at like the low level of evil yeah
that's evil yeah and there were there
was one guy who crossed his arms and
refused to salute Hitler yeah I don't
think every single person is capable of
it even if you don't go for it I think
you're making the argument about the the
disconnect we're having is that you're
making an argument about the physical
capabilities versus what I'm saying is
the internal desires correct yeah you
don't have to have the design there's
clearly a range of people some again
some people cluster B some people
traumatize some people selfish some
people are more inclined towards it than
others one thing that I will say that I
agree with you a lot is that some people
that I've met in my life they're like oh
I could never do that I could never do
that and then they totally do it so it
would have actually served them to have
that conversation with themselves that
you're talking about well I think it's
important to have that conversation I'm
not talking about uh physical capability
I'm talking about internal desire
some people have no internal desire and
are not at risk of being evil people
well even if you don't have the desire
you can still the bit There's Something
Something Beautiful when you recognize
how good it makes you feel to be
altruistic to have integrity to add
value and then what starts to happen
when you recognize that and you have a
transformation there then you actually
lose those good feelings when you do bad
things so you actually have an internal
regulation because you realize that
you're Contracting and shrinking when
you act like that so you and you can
actually take very dark people and
expose them to that and they can have a
change but they'll they'll often resist
them yeah they can have Redemption yeah
because we're all capable of that as
well
that's kind of what I meant about some
people from early in the conversation
even if they're not going to do it but
always a chance
so I guess the way I see it is there are
some people
who you know in my experience have been
like that's really cool man like I hope
things are great I have one friend who
is like very Lefty and like still one of
my best friends and they're just like I
don't care about anything else like
you're you're my friend and like we
don't really ever talk about any
hardcore political stuff even though I
see what their posts on social media are
and there are some people who are like
legit hangout everyday best friends who
were never political and then all of a
sudden were like oh now's my chance to
get famous and make money I'm like
clearly one person is evil and one
person is not and the person I see as uh
not evil is political with Lefty values
but they're based on ignorance so
there's you know there
they're not I'll put it this way they're
not overtly political going out and
joining activists or anything they're
just posting memes and stuff and they
don't they don't know better and so I
suppose in that sense you could say
there's a capability of the banality of
evil which I understand and would agree
with but I think there are certainly
people who are legitimately and
genuinely evil maybe the better way to
put it is yes everybody is capable of
evil but there are some people who are
downright evil and only being stopped by
committing evil acts due to fear of
physical suppression I think that's true
too your analysis too of like some
people fiscal suppression some people
ridicule some people have ethics and
morals and there's a range of different
people but like a lack of desire to be
evil you know there's some people who
are just like I have no interest
whatsoever and but you know what's funny
about that there's even a range to that
I think Jordan Peterson talks about this
where it's like you see some of these
people that are very very passive like
they're very very chill but then they're
the same people that will vote for a
lockdown right so it's one of these
things where
um Jordan Peterson will say that you
have to be dangerous to even be
trustworthy like be dangerous but then
don't use it so it's one of these things
where how much proactive Consciousness
does someone even have in their mind
mind maybe how much are they even in
touch with their own thinking I think
maybe we're defining evil differently I
suppose but it's it's interesting to
think about like somebody who would be
you know Pro lockdown right and they're
just kind of passive and they're not
really digging into it like I don't know
it's all good like like when I see
people that are easily bent I don't
trust them people that are easily bent
scare me because they're the people that
will be weaponized by some psycho and
then and then what the psycho will do is
shift the Overton window to say oh this
is good and this is bad and then the
past of people are just like okay just
following orders and like to me that's
evil I view it I view it like this in in
the way you mentioned it like what
amount of value on the table would make
you uneasy and for me it's like
literally none like like there could be
you know billions of dollars and I just
be like I don't know but you're an
exceedingly principal I mean I mean you
Luke like and I'm just getting to know
you but I bet you you are the same from
what I mean like Luke has run into riots
in Hong Kong you know with a gas mask on
to go reveal the truth that's not an
average person you've done similar types
of things that's a very different type
of person like there is no circumstance
at any point where if I found a wallet
in it I would take the cash out and
check the wallet no I'm the same way so
why are you like that that's right I
don't know because I know there's
reasons though because I don't like
I somebody needs that wallet back yeah
it's also that you understand that that
you're being a piece of crap and that
would lower your self-esteem
it's not just that it's like I've been
homeless before you know so you have a
higher degree of empathy
it's not even that it's like dude your
money does nothing for me it it moves me
in no way so maybe what you're saying is
that once you reach Financial abundance
no no I'm saying that like I don't want
to be involved with you I'm saying that
I would rather dig through the dirt to
find bugs to eat than have anything to
do with you like I don't want to be
responsible for other people I don't
want to take for them and be responsible
for their misfortunes misdeeds or
fortunes leave me alone let me do my
thing I'll figure it out so for you it's
about self-efficacy it's about
it's it's about in in infringing upon
another person I don't want the
responsibility I don't wanna I don't I
don't wanna hold your kid like you come
with your baby I'll be like I I your kid
is very beautiful very cute I'm very
happy for you I don't want that
responsibility sorry I just so you just
really really like to do your own thing
I like to be left alone and I don't want
to be responsible for other people yeah
and then it's an interesting predicament
you know running a company and and
having to be because that's a natural
part of reality but my point is like I
would rather be homeless foraging for
food than stealing someone's wallet or
exploiting their Misfortune for me I
wouldn't take the wallet because I think
life is a test on your morality and you
will be judged based on your behaviors
so that's why I wouldn't do it
personally myself and to add you to the
context of what you were saying here MLK
always of course has this famous quote
saying in the end we will remember not
the words of our enemies but the Silence
of our friends and I think that's where
you're kind of getting into in time
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time